again oh my god it hasn't been a good
morning and so long ain't that the truth
we are so excited to be back on the air
we're so excited to be gracing as the
morning toast hashtag rebrand
we've always said we love a rebrand and
that's exactly what's happening here
today but before we begin our fabulous
show for you we just want to take one
moment to once again apologize for the
things that we've said in the past
better
toast
toast will continue to be a happy fun
positive and kind of escape our so we
love you Oh toast will continue to be
fun loving everyone could be entertained
by so without further ado Jackie stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
considering this morning we decided to
take all of us and work out the fast
night stories up and we took suggestions
from world famous morning morning toast
Facebook group if you're not in it
you'll get there soon it's really like
the most premium group on Facebook at
the time it really is the top of this
like it once you're in it becomes your
whole face premium content didn't keep
my friends like getting engaged because
I'm so keeping up with the toasters I
don't keep up with the Joneses I came up
with the toasters I am the toasters okay
this first story happened a while back
but we never had to talk about it and
there's there's so many like truly like
an ogre there are layers to the story so
many layers and we're gonna break it
down layer by layer because Ahriman Doug
jr. and Lauren Burnham are engaged after
the bachelors shocking ending which was
not shocking if we tried to avoid
spoilers and at every cost I found out
you know I embrace the spoilers like
once I really want to know something
crazy I don't know if you know this that
this boy it was spoiled in our Facebook
group someone saw the ABC cameras at
Lauren's house and put the photos in our
people reality Steve took them from
there are delays but group it's always
causing trouble he didn't know that
because we were deleting everything
because I didn't want to be spoiled
because it's a no spoiler group penny
will always be drama for a Daily Mail
with Kylie
and now reality Steve with Lorne be
great so thank okay makes you think
alright jr. is officially engaged again
the bass are and Lauren Burnham are
engaged a couple revealed during after
the final rose special on to eight
twelve weeks ago sorry can I just say
look how excited I am to be like talking
about dumb [ __ ] and it's so fulfilling
shallow wet and it's all this stuff was
happening I thought about it but like
it's truly upsetting when you have no
that's you're using as a high school
principal today I'm just like what would
happen if Lisa banner became the
principal of a middle school and you
know what I would feel sad for those
kids because she's the most manipulative
[ __ ] ever and you don't doing that
you
101 with LBP this morning that comment
and how pertinent it is to what's going
on in Beverly Hills right now we are
gonna recap all the shows every single
show we have this so much to talk to you
guys about so we're just gonna start
just quickly she's re and Lauren I don't
need to read you the story because we
lived it unfortunately and there's so
much opinions about it every burst of
all we need to talk about how they film
the breakup mm-hmm no edits like I
appreciate you guys trying to be real
for the first time like can you cut it
up a little bit Jackie was totally oh
and like re I don't know how I feel that
all right but what he basically said
because people were like it's kind of
[ __ ] up if you like bring a camera
crib I'm like shocked Beca with a
breakout on camera and he was like I
really wanted her to have the option of
being about tret which when I heard that
I'm like that's so nice actually like
that make sense but why would them
breaking up have anything to do with
because like the public is like the
outpouring of support for Becca and her
venmo account like that like so lame
she's so like BuzzFeed you know totally
before she was dumped internationally on
TV like she was just another she was we
liked her just as much as we liked more
it actually everyone always hated Lauren
but I find that I said from the
beginning ever since they like first her
conversation on the show I really
thought she was a contender and by the
way I did not win my bracket even though
it's so confusing because I had Becca is
the winner and technically she got the
vibrator right that's fair you should
technically win I don't I don't know I
knew Lauren B was like a serious
contender when she was giving me Sean B
vibes because like she on beat
literally couldn't handle being in a
relationship with someone who was like
going on dates with other girls and she
liked how to break down very early on
being like I literally like I liked him
so much I can't handle this like that's
such a normal reaction and the fact that
more people don't have that kind of
reaction on the show right he's like
proof that it's all of ours yeah and
it's a part
asked me the other day do I still have
my ear as far as to you and they do yes
I finally got past the stage of the
worst stage oh my god it's disgusting I
hated cleaning the smell this it's a pus
sniff it smells like your bellybutton
there was one time where I thought like
I went a few days without cleaning them
and I thought my ear was getting really
puffy and I thought it was the end of my
parsing but I made it through the other
side and now in the girl both parties
literally made it through the other side
of your ear and now I'm so excited to
like wear fun game to your wedding to my
wedding okay that's another story and
they're obviously a 2 but we will get to
everything
we'll get to just be patient wait I had
wanted to overshare something I wanted
to pull up the stream to see how I
wanted to overshare speaking of Billy
bottles and like puss been like believes
he suffers from a disease because like
everyone's bellybutton smells like don't
get me wrong but Ben has like a crazy
smelling bellybutton we're like his
head's up here and he could smell his
bellybutton like just I'm like standing
up and he's really worried about it cuz
like he thinks he has an infection and
he takes such good care of it like he
like cleans it all the time alcohol pads
I'm like it still smells
no it's Christian he's like so like
embarrassed of it and now I'm like
blowing up his spot but last night like
I'm obsessed with like Ben and like it's
like or isn't like just trying to like
put squeeze great you support yes oh
yeah thank you
I actually prefer to be a guidance
counselor that snacks yes Oh miss suffer
this is you come to me with a problem
hey mister
so everyone my classes being like really
really mean to me and getting picked on
and I don't know I don't know how to
handle it
well it sounds like you deserve it cuz
you're so been like I always am
obsessive like popping his pimples and
just like doing stuff to him and then he
like never lets me it's so annoying last
night like laying can I look inside your
belly button like he said he thinks
there's something wrong like let me just
take a look with my flashlight only
because you keep sticking your fingers
no but I'd never last night was the
first time you went into the Jeep I went
into the web of Ben's bellybutton it's
so deep he's like a big guy like he's
like tall broad like a little chubby
like he's big all around and so his
bellybutton reflects
it is so deep I couldn't even find the
bar as you said a big belly button it's
a sign of strength it's a sign of
strength and you know us you know Jessie
ladies call it the belief at all yeah so
much you found like I my name with a
q-tip and there was nothing out of the
ordinary but it was just an exciting
like journey to be on you know I feel
like Ben's bellybutton is the eighth
wonder of the world know for sure you
should have put some of it on a petri
dish I felt like I was at the beach you
know like you're digging a hole like
you're digging a hole to China but like
you never get to the bottom that was
Ben's bellybutton I didn't find the
bottom actually there were so many
layers
yeah it's like Mary Poppins bag you know
that's me cold the lamp out of it like
that episode where we talked about that
I actually watched the highlight we all
recently and I could not stop laughing
there's just a crazy thing no oh my gosh
it was amazing another segment where
we'll have like interesting people come
on yeah what is your belly button smelly
me use one word - there's a cut your
bellybutton deep no I got it on heart
yeah okay let's give it to Lauren oh
okay because I feel like they've been
getting so much hate like public press
about the fact that they're like thirst
monsters they want a public they want a
TV wedding like they're your vacation I
feel like they don't want special
treatment like all the bachelor people
want that they're all first monsters
generals like why born and are you
getting like so much press about it
they're all the same
everyone wants a televised wedding
everyone wants a PFR of a kitchen
everyone is thirsty as hell oh and by
the way that's not just bachelor people
the whole world would like a free
vacation I would literally get divorced
and get remarried
yeah I would leave Greg okay okay wait
then we need to talk about I bought your
house is about Lana last night and it
came back okay we'll talk about it later
yeah we're not in the TV segment yet so
Becca's a bachelor now okay and a lot of
actually our toasters who are in our
Facebook group have been going to the
dates as like extras you know they yeah
they cast extras to be like in the
audience to be whatever and we've been
getting some really good scoop in the
group apparently there's only nine guys
like I need you the group's good there's
only nine guys left it's so fast and
they went to Richmond Virginia I think
and like other other uninteresting place
Richmond merging is a great place to
bomb it really is deep rooted in
American history though that's true I
think it's a great place to fall in love
just as great as Fort Lauderdale they
really go downhill so crazy when they
literally have the girls being like Fort
Lauderdale's whoo perfect place to fall
and they're on a balcony and they're
like oh my God look what that's how you
know those people are paid actors yeah
of course the show you can get that
excited about Fort Lauderdale we've been
so many timing that I can never know
enough to that we can say they'll be
looking the stream do we look pretty
today um you look good I am just
principal Jackie are you gonna wear your
culottes again tomorrow
yes because these are dirty culottes
well I'm actually wearing dirty jeans
like six dancing around these are
definitely dirty culottes like three
days in a row because for literally
eight months remember I wore these pants
of when Ramsay was on the show whose
Rancic Oh get Nancy I'm sorry
no Nancy you said I didn't know you're
talking about so when she was on the
show then they disappeared for literally
eight months when I was moving which
I'll get to in a little bit I found them
and then I can't take them off how sad
that you've lost them
you don't like my cool apps I just added
the cool and cool jacket I have to say
something like I love you anything that
they say I think you are just like so
brave in your fashion choices sometimes
and
you wear that share jumper dress like
you made me died like these pants are
horrible
you yourself so much and you're fit but
like this is I'm an engaged woman I'm a
married woman
and I don't trust like that and I just
every day the third grade
culottes blacks they are 100% Gauchos
you can call them whatever fancy word
you want I have the same pair from
forever 21 and they're called Gauchos
Wow okay
I'm not gonna stop wearing them but I'll
stop wearing them on this show mostly
because they look really bad yeah but
it's fine you know
everybody makes mistakes everybody has
those days but do you follow the
mornings when Ariana Grande of course I
do I'm enjoying me damn them she is so
gorgeous
like she wins and I really think that
they're perfect for each other yes like
maybe Ari's not the right guy for you
emus yeah but I think they're great
together they're both boring they both
want the same things and they both like
each other and that's really all that
Matt I want them to prove everyone wrong
because like I love when the media is
wrong by the way how badly do you think
they want to prove everyone wrong I
think even if they're fighting to the
death they will not break up but like
what's annoying is like I think Jourdan
and Jojo are thirstier and like more
obvious about like their wanting for
fame like [ __ ] Jordan went to the
work at ESPN like they're just so
obvious and no one's talking about it
but like Lauren already just have like a
nice life and Arizona and like they're
getting [ __ ] for it it's like pissing me
off no and it's like you go on The
Bachelor with the hopes of a TV wedding
like no way that's I want to go in the
bachelor to have a quiet life right said
nobody ever and and pay for my own
wedding yeah I really want someone to
get married soon and honestly it's just
so crazy like you think you know a
couple when they're on the show and then
they like graduate whatever the word is
and they're so different like I really
think that Rachel and Brian are like
number one I think they're gonna like be
together I'm gonna be the first to get
marry you need to like they're so cute
Zach's mom saw that them at the airport
the other day and she said that they are
so in love yeah like I don't know I just
get like a really good feeling with them
and I just want to say I [ __ ] love
Rachel Lindsay I [ __ ] love her like
no one can make me not love Rachel
Lindsay never
she's been nicest girl I've ever met
yeah and the most like I love that she's
a lawyer like I just love her yeah I'm I
think that there she got a really bad at
it like on behalf of ABC making her look
stupid with like Peter and that's so not
how it happened no she's old us and like
everything happened the way that it
should Peter Estela prince was promised
to make his boot camps all over town
except he posted a cryptic Instagram the
other day I saw like that he might be
seeing someone
no I I can't see Peter with like a woman
yeah I see Peter with a Peter Peter with
a mirror yeah no I don't see Peter with
a man I don't see Peter with a woman I
see him with like his dog and like
George Clooney dives yeah and then I
[ __ ] hate them like that and Cameron
Eubanks like in the back I go Peter I
love Kevin Eubanks southern charm we
will get so that we will get to our
second there's a particular story here
that I'm like dying to talk about really
yeah I told you in the car today I
forget what's the next story cardi B
revealed to me from SNL on Saturday
night and you know what I'm so excited
for her she looked unbelievably gorgeous
in that white dress and it's just so
incredible how long she was actually
able to keep it secret for huh and she
was wearing speculation I'm pretty sure
she like outright denied it and lied
yeah because she was really pissed
someone in her camp like leaked it it's
her secret to lying out totally and I
like oh she was dressing up her bump and
we don't even know it like but now I'm
looking back I'm like oh she really did
like wear puffy things oh yeah I love
her I think the way she did it was like
so Beyonce maroon Beyonce did love on
top yeah at the VMAs and that was like
the most iconic performance ever cardi B
is like giving me Beyonce vibes like
that and I'm just like I shouldn't make
it like a big deal like the Kardashians
are like Chloe's thing it's like so much
like just have the baby and shut up you
know who I saw last me who Tristan
Thompson
I forgot to tell you what yeah he was at
Nobu and like people are saying I don't
think I don't know that that she had a
baby that she hasn't posted on social
media in a few days that she went into
labor so what is he doing in New York at
Nobu I do not know I do not know and
someone said they saw him at up and down
one of our group oh yes so what she
looks like
our group is like farce comes like yeah
everywhere everybody most major
historical moments that really don't
have any significance but we think yeah
so back to her DB I just like the
subtlety of it all because she's not
really subtle but like I don't know
everything's happening for her all at
once and I'm so excited I feel like
she's handling it like a championship
except I now that we are free from the
restraints of Corporate America I could
talk about some lines for those of you
don't know blind items are blind gossip
that honesty has proven itself to be
true time and time again we've read them
back in the day I read one website quiz
it is a nice I don't trust any other
website there's also another one couple
I got it I don't trust them because they
say the most outrageous [ __ ] that's like
definitely not
I don't think they ever tell you who it
was so but crazy days might eventually
tells you who they were about from three
years ago and then it turns out he was
right about everyone right so basically
what happens is that like he writes
these items it's like a riddle almost
he's like this is an a-list movie star
who's married to a b-list reality star
and you have to guess who it is and they
say like it's on drugs or like they see
crazy stuff I'm back in the day when I
read in high school like I was just so
naive he would say stuff about like
people having abortions and I'm like
that is not true but now I'm like a
woman I'm like he definitely under
Devlin I'm worried like he had a deal
but I only trust crazy days and nights
and what they say about Hardy being the
only thing they say is that she is
spending all the money she's making like
and now she's putting everything on the
label because she's like they say she's
spending upwards up like hit 50 grand a
day I'm like glam travel makeup hair and
she's only making on average like 10
grand a day that's what they say oh my
god that makes me really sexy I was just
about to say I feel like she's handling
the newfound theme so good but not
financially well I feel like the baby I
mean that's another financial burden
like it'll be good for her career and ya
know for sure I hope her album does well
I think it's already doing well I had
not listened to it but I walked on SNL
and I watched a few clips from SNL it
was like the only time I actually wish
that I had watched it yeah but I wish
that they made cardi be the musical
performer and the whole I know I would
they do that and she's so dynamic like
not just her singing or her rapping but
her like personality she would be so
funny it's really sexy I usually watch
SNL every week now I find myself
watching but Ben's birthday was Saturday
yeah and I don't have TV yet I can't
believe that you have movies I have
Apple TV oh that's good and I have my
iPad which has save lives for everyone
who made fun of me
doubters non-believers once workers
dreamers once we locations including
right now my rose gold iPad matching our
rose gold set yeah it's good a to Ocasek
hard to be an upset at me baby yeah what
I didn't babysit gonna be on set party
party
they're gonna it's gonna be a weird it
was something like creative creative I'm
excited I was feel bad for those kids
saying time yes and no like I don't feel
better rich and famous and like they can
literally fart and the media writes
about it like it's the most amazing
smelling fart since like
mine but but then the offset is the
offset is that you have a crazy name but
I think that you know you got away
checks and balances I did you see in one
of cardi songs she has a lyric about
having a threesome with Chrissy Teigen
and I forget what the other person is
maybe JLo no yeah it was cool oh my god
I didn't see that yeah I'm living under
a rock totally because we haven't been
doing the toast it's true I've been
actually very removed from like gossip
because we're not forced to be informed
the only thing that's keeping me
informed is the toasters thank you guys
doing the Lord's work but now I'm gonna
be back to knowing everything including
all the celebrity breakups which is our
third story of the morning so dramatic
we chosen the top five wow there's so
many there are so many and the first one
I think that started the chain reaction
veining Gigi oh right kind of crazy
shocking shocking I love the thing I
like about Gigi it's that she's like a
boyfriend slide so she's not like really
slept but like she has lots of
boyfriends yeah and it's like
respectable cuz she has like two year
relationships she's a nice girl but she
does she like dates nice guy
age-appropriate yes so I'm excited to
see who she's who she's gonna date now
that's what I was think I kind of hope
she date someone like less famous in her
like the Cody Simpson route ain't she
like bringing said not the winter
because I just like to like learn about
many people you know like people Cody
Simpson wasn't able to sustain the the
Gigi Hadid like Fame afterwards I feel
like Australia and like I don't know
remember they do there but like I'm
hopeless pair up with someone oh this is
Matt Harvey I know but she's LA actually
no she's Newark
she's New York no I really don't think
that they're right especially yo me
neither man about here um nothing bad
just we met some one of our guests with
who's friends with him you're like why
don't you guys date I don't remember
what else I don't know I feel like she's
just gonna like pick someone out pluck
someone from obscurity you know I would
prefer that like Zayn was like an
obvious choice you know what he's like
obviously famous and rich like what
about like someone who like could use
the money you know I couldn't really use
like it he'd wanted to go guys I would
totally go with her and I would get so
many Instagram followers
I'd be so down and she's gorgeous like I
guess I could do it
things and then ever getting out your
mantra this is only perks about dating
GJ yeah and then maybe you would see
your stepdad in law after you get to see
you stepped out of law and good to hang
out at Mohamed's house which is so nice
you get to hang out you'll monta grow
lemon and you can cameo on any reality
show you want the end it would make up
ties to every single / - Kim
Kardashian's barely famous Beverly Hills
barely famous second Wives Club for the
three of us who watch not included in me
I liked it I had a better judgment I had
to watch second Wives Club I will live
at you know what's funny is that I
watched second wives hub and I've never
seen first wives sub I think I have it's
not the one with Melanie Griffith I
don't know I could confuse me that First
Wives Club the women the would Eva
Mendes like I just get confused but you
know I'm gonna see about when I'm so
good were being represented in media
though like seriously yeah here why
reason being like our planes going down
I don't know how to sit like a new
chairs I need an ottoman literally my
legs are crossed like so tight that I
don't even be doing kegels no totally
when I take them apart like they're
gonna be sore
okay so judge insane broke up very sad
we know that he has her eyes his Chanos
so it is it's weird because they broke
up now but it really is so artistic and
she has beautiful eyes yeah and I don't
think he regrets it I know for sure it
was an artistic choice I just feel like
there's nothing regretful about a
beautiful woman I just feel like as a
culture like we should probably stop
doing that like tattooing are lovers
names on our arms and stuff because like
more often than not it doesn't work out
there's a 50% divorce rate in this
country so like maybe there should be a
rule where like you can't get your name
like someone's name tattooed unless
you've been married for at least 10
years maybe or like if you do you have
to have a contingency plan like what you
will turn it into like how Kylie turns
40 into an LA or something like that so
maybe they shouldn't make tattoos so
permanent you know I think that they're
making them last permanent I love
watching those videos on it is saucy
into like a big ugly yeah but none hand
to get like a big ugly dick but I don't
wanna hurt I'm it's okay it's the
physicality of the show these are from
Amazon you get what you paid for
honestly I'm gonna have to tape Jackie's
to the desk because it wouldn't even
stand flat like really Amazon but marki
signs have a
special place in my heart now yeah okay
that's how I supposed to you which we
will get to should have done that first
no but because no because first you have
to start with actually do you like to
start with the good news or the bad news
someone once told me you should always
start with the bad news the news because
you never get to the bad news someone
told me you should always start with the
good news because if you start with the
bad news you never get to the good news
however I like to feel down and then go
up so that's a guy but then you get so
caught up in the bad news you can't even
feel happy you know this is what I'll do
I say give me the bad news you give me
the bad news before I react give me the
good news
let's see where I should be at you just
write them both down like text it's me
right the mode down like jumble them up
and give me a random one but I like to
start with the bad news so we started
with the breakups and then we'll start
with the happy relationships including
my own
next up the if you read blinds the scene
in shock you if you don't rewind you're
shook to the [ __ ] core Jenna
Dewan and Channing Tatum because they
worked so hard to be like the cutest
couple on Instagram yeah I'm not I'm one
that when that role is clearly taken by
me and I write clearly and JWoww and
Roger have been stepping it up with
their oh my god totally oh I love with
Roger I'm in love with him I'm in love
with her we're gonna talk about yours
for sure of course
let's just save it for them but I'm
gonna read the state and they put out so
we can just dissect it bit by bit and
it's so funny because when Roger posted
an Instagram we're not trying to be a
perfect couple with the [ __ ]
statement like he's talking about just
one and Jenna Dewan definitely took that
to heart
totally hey world so it was it weirdly
casual yeah hey well it's a chrissy
teigen wrote this so so we have
something we would like to share first
off it feels odd that we have to share
this kind of thing with everyone but
it's a consequence of the lives we've
chosen to lead which we also happen to
be deeply grateful for great sentence
we're living in incredible we're living
in an incredible moment in time but it's
also a time where truth can easily get
distorted into quote alternative facts
wink so we want to share the truth so
you know that if you didn't read it here
then it's most certainly fiction mmm-hmm
unless you read it on crazy days and
nights or it was report about in the
breath oh the toast we're like 20 mins
then we have lovingly chosen to separate
as a couple we fell deeply in love so
many here
to go and have it had a magical journey
together absolutely nothing has changed
about how much we love one another but
love is a beautiful adventure that is
taking us on different paths for now
there are no secrets nor salacious
events at the root of our decision by
the way since like I've gotten so much
more Moira it's out of control
the band's boy red would wear that top
for sure totally black in back my yeah
just each other living the most joyous
fulfilled vibes as possible we are still
family and will always be lovingly
dedicated parents to Everly we won't be
commenting beyond this and we thank you
all in advance for respecting our
family's privacy sending lots of love to
everyone chan and Jenna what I gotta
this is that their daughter's name is
ever leave here like I already came up
with her wedding hashtag Everly ever
after yeah or happily ever laughing yeah
which is something and I'm currently
struggling with but it really should be
a lot easier okay this is the thing back
to the blinds because you know it always
comes back to the bond they are like the
David Foster of news this is this is
what what they're saying on the down low
is that obviously channing cheats on
Jenna cuz like everyone [ __ ] cheats
it's unbelievable but apparently he
cheated on Jenna you know so extensively
that he just you know just be careful
what you do say yeah
no he just contracted something
emotionally physically whatever you want
to interpret yeah just do your own yeah
that's really sad I had friend of lines
like years ago before I even like was
invested in them as a couple that she's
always worried about him cheating and
therefore like it's like a
self-fulfilling prophecy but she's like
so insecure that it really made sense
like their relationship because like it
was so sweet that they met on the set of
step up but like he's like a hardcore
movie star and like she gets to be the
host of So You Think You Can Dance
because she's married to Jenna Dewan to
its world of dance like yeah the lesser
one yeah it's so you think you can fend
for 50 perfect I love that show I do
since I read that blind years ago I've
never liked taking their relationships
super seriously so this didn't come as a
major blow to me nice it did for so many
people like I didn't know that so many
people like ship them and such it wasn't
it shipping it's just that they try so
hard probably because they had problems
to put on like an Instagram face which
is why like when those couples break up
it shocks me the least it's like the low
key people like now everyone's obsessed
with Emily blonde to end John Krasinski
pit like that would shock me they're
very located like
yeah that would be shocking they're
located because they have a real
relationship you know what's like really
weird I still ship Emily Blunt and
Michael Buble me too
like I Jackie I thought they were the
perfect couple it was so classy and it
makes me like so sad like what is he
who's he with it's okay okay he's
happily now right but he actually his
kid I remember I think we reported about
it yeah it was so sad but I think it's
something better okay good but you know
I just still feel I feel like they're
the type of X is that have nothing but
respect and love for each other much
like this statement would lead you to
believe right now they're just like the
more than it analyzed these types of
breakups I'm like I'm not shocked by it
at all like almost like if Chrissy
Teigen and John Legend broke up like I
wouldn't be surprised
no but I would be like really worried
about like the writers at BuzzFeed yeah
so many people would like not be okay
like seriously seriously they would like
need to hire a counselor I think they
would need to hire like a counselor at
BuzzFeed it's so like if you needed like
a safe space I would do it mrs. Stafford
I'm just feeling really upset about John
your [ __ ] loser get out of my office
also I'm not to make this about myself
but I had recently followed Jenna Dewan
on Instagram
oh you did like the week before they
came out because I was watching makeup
tutorials on YouTube and I watched hers
it was really cute she wears no makeup
she's just beautiful like there needs to
be yeah like disclaimer at the bottom
like I just look this way it's so I lose
these products like you still won't look
like me no and it's like don't waste
your money
yeah the cheap stuff is good is good too
because you're always like she put mud
on her face and look great yeah I never
followed her team is around true for
everyone else I follow her like through
the lens of Brad Goreski
she's a bread graske client and he works
with her like once a week so like I got
to see her there she's so skinny so
skinny and up it as like a short girl
I'm sorry
yeah I'm sure excuse me as a short
haired girl she's part of short-haired
girl in spell yeah so like when you need
a hairstyle you go to her Instagram it's
what I've learned from me in the short
hair Club for now like 12 years yeah I
don't remember you with long hair I'm
actually thinking about growing it out
for my wedding but
decided yet but I'll probably wear it up
anyway okay so don't okay you're so much
better joy I know well just right now
you know I can't even talk about my hair
because I'm like a liaison for the
Shorthair committee
okay so Jenna and chatting broke up like
I seriously don't care I'm just excited
to see who he's gonna do next
totally I just wasn't connected to them
at all no me neither except for when
they did lip sync battle but even that
was like so extra so I was watching it
I'm like they're trying so hard but like
they were the perfect people to do it
like she is there time for the answer
and they should really put on it was
great
this next split I could talk about for
an hour but Claudia won't let me Olivia
culpo and Danny Amendola oh my god I'm
just I'm honestly so happy that I don't
have to see like pictures of them at the
Super Bowl anymore I am I'm just like I
know I'm not I'm not obsessed with them
like you were it's just I don't know I
just there's so many layers to why I'm
obsessed with them like one they're both
aesthetically pleasing good together
he's good at his sport so like cool but
then like she's from New England she's
miss Rhode Island he's like the darling
of the Patriots like her dad must have
been yes I just you know yeah her
family's probably released like that's
huge like for a family in New England
but it's like football country yeah I
know but it all started when I mean this
is just my hypothesis he got traded to
the Dolphins in Miami that's a different
lifestyle okay that's not it's a better
or worse about like going on Denver it's
not playing at Gillette Stadium and then
going to back 40 it's not going to Green
Bay and then eating at the what's the
culture the Chive okay there's and
should we be friends with Kristin
Cavallari the opposite I'm saying Miami
is like you know there's a lot of
seduction what's that move principle
seduction like Molly Shannon in Josie in
the pits josie grossy and she comes in
they think she's a sex ed teacher you
know what I lose to a guy named chewy in
the back of the van hotels you
famous couples throughout history that
is become one of my favorite line to Z
that is B no Josie has it meant for each
other famous couples throughout history
I love my birthday party I mean bed
would be Josie and guy oh my god that is
unbelievable we see why do you sound
like a sex ed teacher coming to war in
the class like of the dangers of their
spring break trip in Miami but I think
that's the one that definitely put a
strain on their relationship like
they're not going to join it's important
for someone to know back 40 is actually
very far from jealousy yeah so they
couldn't like go directly after the game
it's like a road trip kind of thing we
have somebody Taylor told me that thank
you okay back 40 is your family's
restaurant and like so they just have
it's all there for them in New England
now Miami throws a wrench into these
plans of course and if there was any you
know insecurity infidelity etc it's only
any heightened by the temptation it's a
temptation and wear culottes okay and
there was reported in blinds and it just
made sense that they broke up yeah no
but I'm excited for both of them to see
who they're gonna do next yeah like
Kristin Cavallari needs like a cute
friend for Danny Amendola yeah because
Jay Cutler who's Kristin Cavallari his
husband now is also the quarterback for
Nashville no her first show but I think
was filming before oh really I think she
must live in Miami he plays for the team
well they live in Nashville they live in
Nashville I'm sure oh my Scottie okay
yeah um he gave a note like Olivia culpo
like she's smart like I like when
celebrities use who they date as like a
career move yeah it's just like a step
yeah so we can Nick Jonas was tap Danny
Amendola was a step she needs like a
movie star
yeah honestly like at Seth MacFarlane
honestly Channing Tatum ah oh oh uh but
I think there's an age difference and
honestly I'm the say something very
controversial like Channing Tatum is
not hot anymore he looks like Ronnie
he's a meathead he's so cute but like he
is hot because of who he is like know
for sure but aesthetically purely
aesthetics I can you saw him on the
street you know why they say like beauty
fades like what's on the inside is
forever so like his insides have always
been good from what we've seen like yeah
he always like it's so gracious that
award shows you know he gives Jonah Hill
the spotlight yeah even when he didn't
deserve it now you know he does but so
I'm gonna be with Jonah Hill Oh 20
Chisholm's so even though his beauty has
faded like what's on the inside counts
and what's on the inside is good stuff
no for sure but like him and she's the
man like was the hottest man alive yeah
like oh my god when I was a kid I was
like in love with him I was just in love
with the movie I think I was honestly
more in love with him remember I totally
we will get to her also oh yeah that's
in our fourth story but yeah we can
theorize who would be a couple should
date that we now have so many people
obviously Matt Harvey yeah that's a
really charity or glad but I feel like
he's into blondes with like a little
like bigger boobs and like a little more
curves and I feel like that's not even a
step up from Danny Amendola that's it's
adjacent it's an adjacent move it's a
parallel move it's a parallel park it's
paralyzing but if you like she was on
Access Hollywood perm or promoting her
new please have me kind of me more new
clothing line in the Astra body and
she's like yes we were all woke up no I
don't want to talk about it wait that
was like such a sad like please don't
make fun of me you know I know because
it's you know but you're really
sensitive about it like it's funny who
cares no it's not it's like I tell you
ugly I tell you what it is it's like I
am very sensitive about being
interrupted about not being megyn kelly
know about being in toast what it's when
I'm speaking and you cut me off to
correct me it's like one the shame of
the crash right and their game and then
two it's like you interrupting my train
of so I'll just wait to correct you
thank you okay I thought it was like I
thought you were so fixated I like me
fixing your own I don't cares it's funny
no it's it's nothing that makes sense
yeah okay okay the final breakup
actually no second class this one's
crazy Brielle and Michael so crazy
because she's been like body as hell on
social media so sorry about this yes you
obviously had like I liked them yeah but
I'm very involved this is what I'm gonna
sit back and sit I have read
toast I have read actually that Brielle
she just turned 21 she had this big trip
in Miami and until then she literally
had never had a drink and I always
wondered how like on the show like Kim's
always drying out of a red cup it's like
not a big deal I wondered why Brielle
was like never drinking with her mom at
wine or whatever so she was to Miami
this is my theory she goes out with Dave
grutman like she's having the time of
her life Larsa Pippen snapchat story
live lalala and like she realizes like
Wow going that's amazing like I could've
been doing this my whole life alcohol
now amazing alcohol is the best now I'm
21 I'm like a fake celebrity I don't go
to school or work in the morning like I
should be going out more then she comes
from to her boyfriend who is on the rise
in an MLB and like baseball player so
minorly
know he just made it to like Chicago
White Sox or Red Sox I always forgot
White Sox
bright stops are Boston whatever so I
think that like he can't drink or play
or anything because a he has a full-time
job and the MLB they have to be an
amazing shape he can't be like doing
drugs didn't like her like going out and
she's just like has no commitments and
just like wants to hang so I think it
just wasn't working out like just like
based on their social like their
lifestyle yeah that but hers changed
overnight right because I think she like
discovered alcohol and was like in love
with it would you choose alcohol over a
man it depends on the man would you
choose alcohol over Ben I think ya know
cuz I know you wouldn't know I would
choose I wouldn't choose alcohol over
Ben but I would choose alcohol over Theo
and I do every Saturday night like I get
drunk Haley I just think about so you
love Ben more than you love the oh yeah
you love your husband more than you love
your son my son it's a dog what this
goes into everything everything I know
but Jackie and Jackie like Tucson if I
see oh it like makes me noise check what
something is calendar like he's [ __ ]
dumb okay well he needs a calendar and
so do you so do you
I do need a calendar I have a calendar
so they broke up that's my theory my my
schedules been more wide open my social
events calendar but I do have a clambake
and trip to the Cape I'm excited to Hue
Brielle dates next she's been hanging
out with Slade a lot who's her
ex-boyfriend who was on the show a lot
he was Hugh minor-league for her yeah
what everything that I've been seeing
about Slade in the group yeah I've been
thinking was Slade Smiley
actually yes oh my god so Brielle sex
boyfriend's name is Slade and she's in
snapchatting him a lot so in our
Facebook group people been putting them
into me like what's going on I'm Yellin
sleepy I want to say I'm you lately
Gretchen Rossi's husband yes that's the
only Slade I know that is disgusting no
I thought they were just hanging out and
being like this is so uninvested jockeys
yeah it's a big problem
no it's just cuz it's overload like I
follow Brielle so if she post something
to our Instagram I see it I don't watch
her lives and screenshot them and I
don't watch her snapchat some people say
anyone can we please skip over the next
breakup like I really don't know we're
just gonna mention it so that you guys
know just in case you've been living
under a rock Kendra and Hank I thought
they were honestly I don't even know I
just don't know anything about that
I don't give a shred of a [ __ ] like
they're like I'm just so look I could
name it actually like it affects that
time with a piece of paper I can eat
7,000 people I care about more 7,000 I
agree with everyone in this room and
like I feel like there has been so much
scandal plaguing their relationship from
like the jump
well me like a year after that I was
like have I ever been like I'm in a good
place has he ever been like not cheating
him yeah or she is she ever been like
not traumatized I don't know I don't
know I just don't know it was like I
know a lot of people were like sad about
it I'm gonna say it I saw it I you know
I hope all is well for her I really
always really liked her and she looks
like Teddy Mellencamp not at all yes at
all okay whatever okay because I really
need to talk about the next hour the
next story is the story that we've been
waiting for the story that we broke then
we had to delete yeah because of legal
Nickelodeon ends their partnership with
icarly creator Dan Schneider not just
icarly victorious
salmon cat The Amanda Show Zoey 101 also
rumored to be the father of Jamie Lynn
Spears ooh okay well like I've never
heard of Dan Schneider because like why
then why would you care about a morbidly
obese children's programming producer
why would you care about this oh my god
penis he looks the way I feel about him
do you know
he personifies everything I feel about
him discuss why would you care about
this okay
basically Dan Schneider was a creator of
like icarly like a ton of really
successful Nickelodeon shows victorious
and there have been rumors about him for
ever but if I know about it other people
must know about it he's apparently like
a rampant rampant child lost her like
every girl he's apparently had many
relationships with a lot of the girls in
the show most notably that girl Quinn
from Zoey 101 she was like his favorite
he has a crazy foot fetish and he used
to run social media like contests here
the show Sam and cat with jennette
mccurdy and Ariana Grande
and he'd be like right Sam and cat on
your foot and tweeted at me and so he
was like soliciting pictures from
footage from the official Sam and cat
Twitter account
he's set the rumors about him are crazy
and the blind items have proof that it's
literally just like this systematic okay
so that's Nickelodeon is owned by Viacom
which is owned by Paramount and this
goes all the way to the top like so many
executives know about it so much money
has been used to bury this the families
like there are people who have been like
parents who've been getting their kids
involved in like some of the Nickelodeon
programming and then when they heard
about it like like a normal parent like
left and got paid tons of money and
we're blackmailed into saying nothing
but some parents like went forward with
it they say Ariana Grande like
specifically like was subjected to a lot
a minute they say that I'm in two minds
like what's just not that were
somatically every day she had her own
show produced by the entertainer like
every day was molested by him and the be
used by him and that's why she went
insane which makes so much so much sense
so much sense so Jamie Lynn Spears so
there's a very real credible conspiracy
conspiracy theory that Dan Schneider
said maybe it's true
no Beyonce didn't carry your own baby
like it's not okay so in the middle of
what was the height of Jamie Lynn Spears
his career she had her own own show on
Nickelodeon which was like the biggest
deal ever her sister was the biggest pop
star of the moment she randomly gets
pregnant when she's like seven we're not
weird when you think about the fact that
the man
reducing her show is a well-known child
monster no if you look at pictures of
her baby
Maddy who's really cute looks very
similar to agitate her and doesn't
really look that much like her dad like
the guy that they created up and if you
read some like if you go there's if you
survive on the internet there's a you
willful damage and you will never be
able to just like look at even the
television again that they could do this
to someone uh-huh
but there are so many reasons as to why
that guy was never the baby daddy right
and it's like chronologically it does
not make sense so go you will read that
Dan shader is a [ __ ] monster mom is
so ugly and disgusting looking I'm not
one to fat shame or body shame but he's
literally the most disgusting man alive
looking oh my god I literally like I
read so much stuff about it I think
there was a Twitter thread that was
clipping clips from his shows that just
shows how inappropriate and twisted his
mind is the way that he was like making
kid sexual connotations yeah like one
kid was reading a book on one of his
shows like fifty Shades of Grey like
that's so inappropriate you know it's
crazy and it's like no wonder why were
so [ __ ] up we all grew up watching Dan
Schneider programming I'm not okay and
they got like it's frustrating because I
wonder if this will ever really come no
maybe not because he's fired and it's
over right but it's it's so bad you know
and I think it all comes back seriously
to the same Corey Feldman thing and it's
so crazy but something that it's you
know but I think it's the same like
brain there's a pedophile and it comes
back to mark sailing - yeah
mark sailing who was puck ungli was
convicted of child porn he was gonna
lick literally in order to get time off
of his sentence he was going to give
names of some of the most well known
child monsters in the industry and
literally two days before he was due
that he committed suicide and even
though there was no notes in the police
report he apparently like had defensive
wounds he didn't really hang himself
like this is this goes so deep into
Hollywood and this is just proof that
Hollywood is so [ __ ] corrupt and
disgusting I can't believe that it took
this long for Dan Schneider to get fired
I like reveling in his misery October
was when all the Harvey Weinstein stuff
came out and
like if why wasn't he fired that day my
time is up
x times up especially for Dan Schneider
I just it's justice needs to be served
and apparently so Amanda by they don't
say it's Amanda Bynes but on crazy days
and ice he's in communication with one
of the ex-child starts who went through
a traumatic experience and has been off
the grid
aka Amanda Bynes she sent crazy days a
night a note when all of this came out
and it was just like two words like I'll
be back soon or something and I love you
I think he very support it like and
basically what she did was that all the
letters were lowercase and she randomly
capitalized like ten letters and the the
capitalized letters spelled out dan did
it it was some serious like 37 primitive
on you know that's what they get on
series of unfortunate events Violet
Beauregarde this episode basically been
just one large promotion for crazy days
a nights Donette yeah the website I do
is from the 1970s but it's worth it
yeah if you just really want like some
deeper intel was that our last story
tensioner well that was our last story
and our fifth story is about my
engagement so Jackie all got engaged I
was there it was crazy it was so
wonderful like it was the whole weekend
was just so lovely filled with love and
just like we're just beaming with just
get away we had I hadn't met Zach's like
extended family like his grandparents
and Zach is so blessed he is for living
grandparents and we haven't had
grandparents I think since we were like
in the sixth grade yeah but maybe the
long ago you were in the sixth grade I
think I was in the ninth grade
it was just like so special to be with
like a family who's like they're so
close they all live in Dallas like and
the grandparents I'm in love with
grandparents are incredible in general
totally and I got so much wisdom in like
hey y'all know this you know like old
people have wisdom but it's just like a
history book completely of life
experiences not a boring text milk and
it's just such a beautiful thing and
everyone want to know like how it
happened
so a few like two weeks before Zach had
scheduled a dinner with me and
his sister and her boyfriend and so I
always like was planning on going which
was regular do you guys do that a lot
yeah we do that a lot like I was
actually even I was gonna wear some some
cos awesome cool well I'm so glad you
did when karlie texted me that morning
she's like what are you wearing tonight
and I was like I don't know he's gonna
wear like trousers and Harley is XO sir
yeah and she was like oh okay I might
wear a dress and I was like oh we're
dressed - plus the weather was so nice
and beautiful he's in a bleep war so
it's like beautiful I'll wear a dress I
wound up just putting on an easy dress
and as I was putting it on I was
thinking I was like I'm really wasting
all of my go dresses to get engaged him
because it was like a white lace
self-portrait which is so bright Bravo
and the week before I wore an even more
beautiful white lace self-portrait but I
was like you know what this dress is
okay I'll find a better one when I know
it's happening I did not know what was
happening and you know I did not know
because I did not do fresh makeup and my
face is 12 different colors thankfully
for facetune it's no one needs to know
it's now just five thankful for Anthony
Vasquez no one needs to know right so oh
yeah because I didn't even have to - I
went down to the dinner I literally it
was not suspecting a thing I even like
we shaved my legs I was wearing a dress
when I thought I was gonna pan so they
cut myself shaving and I don't care I
didn't noticed I was in the car and I
was like oh and I get to the restaurant
I was just like go to the bathroom and
wipe it off so I have blood on my leg I
don't know but yeah in the pictures that
they have to be retouched and we're
walking towards the restaurant and then
on the pier I see like rose petals and
Zack at the end with like marquee lights
that say marry me and I literally chat
yes like I was so so surprised and over
without rare to be like genuinely
surprised because everything gets ruined
with like social media like I can't
believe that you didn't know and because
like I really was trying to sniff it out
like there were a couple things that we
had coming up and I'm like it'll
probably be at one of these or what the
next one he invites me to a dinner I
thought it was definitely gonna be on a
weekend cuz I thought maybe some more
out-of-towners and it was a little
earlier than I think you expect it yes
which was really great for the surprise
better early than life so he was on a
Wednesday which I just never thought it
would be on Wednesday just in case like
people feel more out of towners wanted
to come in but the outer tatters came in
mm-hmm and I just did I didn't expect
that and just a whole rest of the
weekend was amazing oh my god it's just
like such good food such good times so
much singing so much singing and dancing
yes sister Zach's brother is like an
actor so he's a very theatrical and like
physicality and Zach's dad is an amazing
singer so like and obviously I'm like
Mariah Carey so like just between the
three I was like and between me just
being he was singing everywhere
everywhere it was fantastic
it was really fantastic a lot of
greatest showmen - yes and honestly
throughout all the time that we were
gone and like some there were some
moments that were like really actually
very difficult for me listening to the
greatest showmen soundtrack like a
really was extremely uplifting and
extremely helpful
I completely agree it's so many
inspiring words it's just music in
general like this is gonna sound so
cheesy you know I agree
it really has a way to relate to
anything that you're going through to
the point where you feel like oh wow
this person also went through hell right
I needed the Kacey Musgraves album to
come out when it did yeah because and I
love the chronology of it where it
starts out like with a breakup and it's
sad but then you come out to this
rainbow and your golden hour and it's
just like it's a whole journey it's a
journey exactly it's a journey
Kelsey ballerinas album is very similar
you go from graveyard to roses to
in-between to unapologetically in love
to legends yeah so it's just magical and
now I'm like Jackie's unofficial wedding
planner where I'm like being so negative
about everything planning my wedding and
like a Jackie's like excited about it
I'm like it sucks no I'm just I'm not
cut out for it much like I'm not cut out
for decorating a home like I know I have
a certain skill set like I can wear a
pair of culottes like no one else
she thinks but I'm not an interior
decorator done and that's fine it's
definitely on a bit easier when we first
moved in together which we moved in
together a few like after no one has
been I haven't even been to your
apartment oh yeah because it's not ready
when we first started shopping for
furniture like it was painful painful
like you know I'm pink and I'm girly but
I wasn't even trying to be like you
gotta meet in the middle I was like okay
we could do you know like let's go
Silver's blues a lot of maritai denim
love neutral and he was just like not
coming to the party was a gray but gray
background
I was like this can't happen no it can
so we finally went furniture shopping in
a Dallas and just we hit up all the
spots all the hot spots including Z
Gallerie which saved my life it's the
best or the best store and we got our
couch from there it hasn't come yet and
I'm literally so excited like I dream
about sitting on my couch and watching
great a showman I just like go into
people's houses when they haven't moved
in yet and they've nowhere to sit that's
why I have not invited anyone they think
they're doing me a favor and I'm like
don't they just stay home you can come
over in a month maybe five to seven
businesses yeah five to six weeks five
to six week we have so much TV to recap
I did spend a lot of time watching TV I
know so let's let's talk about what's on
today seven minutes okay okay we're
gonna run down everything that we caught
up on which is Beverly Hills is on
tonight where where are you at I'm at
where like I I just think it's so funny
because me and my group of friends which
is like my best friends from high school
like we always think we're the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills like we just
like we do parties no we don't do it
that way but just like we're always
Beverly oh she she she she she and we
took a trip to Berlin years ago and it
was like traumatic for us we went to
Florence and it was amazing and we
decided to make it like a two-parter
where we went to Berlin afterwards I
don't know why we chose Berlin we had
the worst time like we couldn't find
anything to eat because we're like half
kosher some of my friends are allergic
to dairy like we couldn't find anything
good about a good meal
we tried so hard to turn up to you stay
at the hotel that they say I've seen at
the Ritz it was a gorgeous the hotel was
the best part we had like a standard
room for $100 a night do you have a
panic room no it was the best hotel I've
ever stayed in yes yeah it was so cheap
it was international Ritz as I guess are
cheap so worried we couldn't get a meal
we tried so hard to like turn up and get
bucked up we couldn't find a club it's
all like underground bars we couldn't
they were still underground we couldn't
find them we literally ends up at a teen
club I love me too but I was just like
the idea so the fact that we're so Mary
came Ashley totally and the fact that we
think we're Beverly Hills housewives and
like they went to Berlin like Berlin is
like our thing yeah it's just I'm loving
watching it cuz like you could tell
Berlin so sorry it does this is what I
think I I cried twice three okay you let
you Lynn
oh my god was so sad Doreen so sad it
means so much
I really I like trying keep saying that
this season they liked her even less I
really I'm liking her yes she keeps
stepping in it but someone has to
because Lisa Rinna have you get herself
out of the game
and I love Lisa Rinna and you know what
it's here's what's happening it's slow
but sure the reckoning of Lisa
Vanderpump is coming yes he's been
waiting for this for years because she's
out I always turn down Kyle has always
been the key if we wanted to take LVP
down Kyle was a girl she almost did it
with Brandi and the magazines in the
trip to Mexico she she ate [ __ ] at the
Reunion and totally turned back and then
she learned her lesson from them and
never did it with Munchausen she said I
don't care about whatever Lisa did to me
I'm sorry I don't care yeah so lame he's
not in the mood to play chess with Bobby
Fischer yeah who is you know how to play
chess yes you do no I know we like to
learn when we were younger but like I
just like I I can't like it's like I can
move the pieces in the way they're meant
to be moved but like that's what you do
there's no strategy no who's a thought
behind it no okay this is where a map
says a lot about us
Teddy is like really pissing me off
she's her and LVP being stole up each
others butts I was shocked when Lisa
literally was like Teddy stop yeah like
that was crazy you're so rude her color
is head chef it's just it's so
hypocritical I'm hating Lisa and to eat
like so what Lisa can literally speak
for Joe read but Teddy can't chime in
for two seconds
no I have no defensive Teddy I'm just
like I just want Lisa to keep on burying
her something too and I like to read and
like yes she great what's up wait but
when Teddy told Rinna what Tariq said
about her three months ago insane and
this wasn't wrong to say yes if they had
apologized and move forward but then she
the jury capya what had happened okay
and this is like yes you can apologize
but it just takes time like this is how
you know the devil when she said to Lisa
Rinna you've been so not engaged so this
event is finally behaving you're so many
charge you say something mean about Lisa
Rinna every chance you can in your side
contrary side commentary is all about JD
she's so shaded Erica she's associated
everything and like so she's now being
mean to Lisa Rinna that we had to this
child
you're [ __ ] petulant
I I put on my my snapchat story that I
decided I'd who did I say was that is
the greatest housewife of all time
LuAnn oh and she is I stand by that
statement and so many people were back
to me like Diana Ross oh my god we have
to talk about that that was not okay
okay
I've started to say when LuAnn walked
out in her costume we're skipping out
franchises but when she lucked out in
her costume this was me is that no it
can't be
is it it totally is back everyone was
responding to me when I said LuAnn was
the best no LVP LVP she's like well
regarded and respected as a number one
housewife of all time and I'm here to
debunk that rumor down to the ground
that's why it's like that's why she
won't be taken down but that's why it
would be so beautiful if she did and
Reena and Erica are sitting back and
watching I'm not touching this with a
ten-foot pole
they're gonna let her and never handle
herself Erica got involved for two
seconds said one thing to Teddy and
everyone in the group can't get over it
it's better than me
yelled at by my word she was like yeah
don't [ __ ] call me a liar by the way
if you want to see if we want to start
[ __ ] if you want to start [ __ ] with me
whenever getting back to you is fair
game uh-huh
if it's too extreme but she called her a
liar and she said don't do that
literally she couldn't handle Erica
yelling at her for ten seconds and
literally it's been like her downfall
like no one can get past that Erica said
one everything nothing wrong nothing you
want to start with Erica you're gonna
get Erica you asked for furry to sing
the national anthem you're gonna get
Fergie okay so but uh episode go by
without talking about Mason little Hank
William oh my god okay so we're gonna
recap let's recap the rest of the show
so he goes on because he never leaves
his home say about that banner primroses
on tonight we'll talk about it tonight
I can't deal with the fact that they're
fighting over something that can be just
show Jackie video said Hank he said hey
I kept rewinding I'm like did he say hey
no there it's cuz they're literally too
drunk to [ __ ] yeah and I actually
believed them that they did not hook up
no I believe it too it's it's definitely
weird and fishy and they shouldn't be
hanging out like that but I believe that
they didn't hook up me too
and they said hang and production needs
to show
you know but they're gonna let it play
out like trading for the view and it's
not fair to James honestly like I
actually feel bad for names no shame and
like Christina's being a sycophant I
feel bad for her too and I feel bad for
law well because she got drinks on her
dress and because she was okay and I
just like I'm I wanted to get with her
little Hank Williams is the man who shot
to fame as a Walmart yodeling boy and
and I'm in love I usually when things go
viral like crazy I'm always sick so
because they're so undeserving like when
that selfie kid from the Super Bowl win
viral he wasn't even funny or cute like
that makes me mad finally we have
something that went viral that was so
deserving because no talent not like
everyone's making fun of him but like he
is so talented I tried to yodel and I
have amazing like vocal abilities I
can't go at all for [ __ ] but here's the
thing like I I love him he's so talented
that initial video was truly incredible
and amazing and funny yes yes but like
every time we see a new iteration of it
like it gives me a no I agree because
like I just want to protect him no I
know and I feel like he doesn't really
understand the scope of what's going on
but like people are laughing at him and
it's like not okay cuz I'm not laughing
at him I'm like enjoying his towns and
now I love Hank Williams I want to
listen to that song about you
[Music]
like I know I feel happy and sad it's
like Kacey Musgraves says I love him no
and I want him to be friends with Jacob
Tremblay once he gets a big I had like
such a kid about this episode I was just
like nervous to come back and like see
what you know what the fans were like
but I feel like I'm happy it's over and
I'm like just really excited to be back
on the test I'm excited to downsize I'm
just excited to just get back to it
speaking of the toast I'm speaking of we
have a celebratory toast obviously
because it's our first episode if you
didn't want to drink on the job but now
that the job is over we can go drink and
take anything to it I'll do it I'm
actually really good I know I'm not be
happy those things just like go out on
their own and it's crazy lets me forget
that you dropped it 12 ways but I can
telling you I think I'm such an expert
okay that week of content and yeah and
it's gonna be an hour every single day
you please don't look at him it anyway
honey yes seriously don't worry
actually those famous last words yeah I
know I like I knew it was coming I
remember the first time I heard
champagne opening when okay so a toast
to the toast
as always the morning toast is available
on facebook Instagram and YouTube live I
recommend watching on Facebook or
YouTube it's a high premium quality
content and it will be in the podcast at
a little later on and we were number two
in the podcast or all weekend so tonight
let's get to my new overall number one
economy obviously because we're the
funniest [ __ ] out there so make sure
you're subscribed on YouTube you like on
Facebook you leave a rate of
subscription this is like a part it's a
parsing farce okay that's good Oh big a
mess a ton you said what do you guys
think of the new society sorry get in
yeah we're gonna get a signed up we're
gonna spruce it up maybe like a
bookshelf you guys the only place to go
is up it's so true cheers here's to the
boys host here's to the toasters whose
support has literally gotten them and
been unwavering and you guys see might
think we don't see your comments see
your look oh please I read everything
that was said about me the good and more
importantly no it's better for it you
guys are incredible I feel so like
grateful to have fans like you you make
doing this worth every ounce
amen they don't know what they're
watching the show I wouldn't be doing it
right nor should be fill a toast to the
toasters in the morning toast we will
see you tomorrow 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
have an amazing an amazing Monday I'm
going to